retired admiral sandy winnefeld was vice
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
from 2011 to 2015. he also led the
military command responsible for
preventing air attacks on north america
and winnefeld is our new cbs news
military and homeland security analyst
he joins us from denver good morning
good morning and welcome back charlie
thank you so much and we're pleased to
have you as part of our team
let me begin with whether you think
north korea is begging for war
no i don't think they're actually
begging for war that was i think a
rhetorical device used by our ambassador
to the united nations i think what what
he really is looking for is a some sort
of a nuclear deterrent that will allow
him to protect his regime the last thing
that he wants is a war right now can we
allow that to happen to him to have that
kind of nuclear deterrence that will
protect his regime
well charlie i think that cat is sort of
out of the bag right now the the goals
right now of course probably should be
to prevent use of a nuclear weapon and
certainly to prevent proliferation of a
nuclear weapon i think kim jong-un in
the last week or so has taken a couple
of steps further down the road to
demonstrate to us that he is working
very diligently towards having that
effective nuclear deterrent so admiral
how would you assess where the crisis is
right now a lot of experts have been
surprised at the weapons capabilities
that north korea has are we keeping up
and how concerned should americans be
today
well first of all this is not all that
much of a surprise the timing was sort
of looking through a glass darkly we
didn't know exactly when some of these
things were going to occur but we did
know that they were going to happen and
now they have
i don't think that americans should be
panicking going over this at all we have
a very good nuclear deterrent
even though kim jong-un will probably
never give up his nuclear weapons he
will not use them as long as his regime
is not perceived to be at risk so i
would
encourage everybody take a deep breath
and let's let this play its course how
can you be sure that he will never use
them
he's been acting fairly rationally and
the reason he would never use them is it
would be as jim mattis pointed out over
the weekend in a very calm and measured
manner it would be suicide if he were to
ever use a nuclear weapon because uh he
would face a very strong retaliatory
response but as as many have pointed out
sometimes these wars happen by mistake
you know they just get stumbled into
agreeing that there are times when he
seems to act rational um admiral a lot
of folks think that china is the key to
all this
um what what approach should the trump
administration be taking right now
china clearly is a very important player
in this crisis they have a lot of
control over whether economic sanctions
will actually work against north korea
i think it's very important that we have
good quiet diplomacy with china right
now they have a party congress coming up
in mid-october the worst thing we could
do right now is put them on the spot
publicly but i think we need to be very
firm with them privately and get them to
back sanctions not only publicly in the
u.n security council but to actually put
the teeth in them on their border thanks
again admiral great to have you thank
you again you too welcome to the team